ん
矢崎さん
4サイクな塩入っている
普通に気になるんだ
儀間学生
26000何エリスミスです
ブーブーウイン絵本たいなってるブーバー今6082んん
がまっ f 第2編で守ってるんです
[音楽]
に泣かないどっ
何で何で今読んでるって言われましたしてないしてねー
[音楽]
まぁねぇどうぞおいと動い努力でミョウ
おいてみよう
じゃあおいてみよ1回を言ってるよええええわぁ
しないよクックパッドのホープだ水ございバイバーイ
ロージーん
[音楽]
ero 4
何とか経営ターゲットの財布だけを置いてって出かけさせたんですけどもう開かれの
財布の中にはいま
まあ2600082円入っていますそう
難解なんですけどまぁ彼ですね結構お買い物っていうかこうなんかスーパーとがよく
行くんですよ
全然知らないんですけど店スーパーとか1分ような気がするんで
多分小銭をすごいたくさん使っちゃうほらだからお札ばかりで小銭が少なかったんです
よね今回ですねちょっと優しい時いるというか彼を幸せにするドッキリです
もし台風の中のお金が全て1円玉に両替されていた時
いやさぞ喜ぶことでしょ絶対喜ば弄って
もう物量的に送れますし見た目も良くなりますしあの大買い物後5分楽になると思うん
ですごい喜んでくれると思いますそんな素敵なドッキリようやっていくぞいまいん
バンッ
大雪で早速この5の中に善玉が260802枚入れていいかと思いますまず100万円
とことも最高の中に何枚入るかというところがポイントススメといってこれで50円
これで100円の量で市の100倍ぐらいだったら多分全然入ると大たことではある
前
前年と入りますさあどんどん増やすいますすごいやばいやばい
パットライン長を兼ね持つあれはさぞ喜ぶことでしょ
今200円入ってますぜひねもう入んない方やまだ言ってる笑ける
水
ブーブー b
ええええええ
[拍手]
本作
see ああああ
[音楽]
26000初11円以前玉にするとこれだけのはこれだけの大金になるんだなという
ことを改めて認識しておりますで版さにヤバイよこれでこれ13と26081枚あり
ます銀行の方で両替していただいてちょっと数えてあるので間違いないと思いますこれ
でターゲットは絶対喜ぶと思うので帰りを待ちますでは
[音楽]
えっ暗い暗い暗い暗いっ
位えっ
ねっ
本年年
怒り狂う
えっ
市兵衛ベル君よって
1えっ
なんでなぜねえこれ全部了解させていただきました
まあん嬉しい嬉しい
パッと見とても悲しんでいるように見えますが
耳をすませると
心の声が聞こえてくるのですありがとう始め
[音楽]
me
ni
あっはぁ
はいというわけでえええ
広範囲な財布の中身が全部5位ために同大するドッキリでした
つか言ってね嫌ならね